i think the prospect of making an
amazing spider-man 3 that seems like a
big leap it does but after the kind of
year we've had or this one movie i could
see a scenario where it could be kind of
possible that they could do it
what's happening there reject nation
greg and john here
today we just got done doing like a
five-hour spider-man no way home live
stream and all i want to do is tell you
to go watch that don't watch this just
go watch the five hours of us all right
now man there's something really
eye-opening about it because while we've
had like talks with friends you know
off-camera like real spoiler-heavy there
hasn't been like a ton of people that
we've gotten to really talk to
spoiler-wise while we were live
streaming hashtag the amazing spider-man
theater chasm three and andrew garfield
hundreds of thousands of tweets sorry
going on and about the big rumor right
now is sony is going to be considering
new multiple projects for andrew
garfield spider-man it was just so
eye-opening in the live stream because
out of five hours kid you not like
throughout the entire time
not really people mentioning tony
maguire
but i would say like a half of the time
people were talking about andrew
freaking garfield and that made me so
happy the live streams should be really
eye opening because they let you know
like what people the biggest takeaway
often tends to be from a movie because
you see what the most reoccurring
sentiments are it was cool to hear
because we both did a re-watch of uh all
the spider-man films prior to no way
home and it was funny because i remember
hopping on the phone with you when i was
like trying to hunt down a new
spider-man shirt at the mall and i was
talking with you about like
because you guys know i've been like a
religious like tobey maguire devotee
like number one pinnacle impossible and
then re-watching all the movies like it
back-to-back over the course of a couple
days i i found myself going i think it's
actually andrew garfield it's my
favorite one i think he's my favorite
and truth be told i've kind of backed on
amazing spider-man 2 and now i i i don't
love it but
i liked it quite a bit
spider-man 3 went down for me and
inspired my one actually i was kind of
surprised we want to do a ranking video
uh especially after realizing just how
much shifting was happening and so i was
exceptionally more excited at the
prospect of andrew garfield popping up
in no way home when we were in the
theaters and then when people saw the
suit of andrew garfield every time we've
seen it the amount of people freaking
out and then when he takes his mask off
the amount of people freaking out
and the fact that the big hype leading
into this and tell me if you agree with
this didn't it seem like
people were mainly about okay maybe
andrew after but toby you're right it's
toby's going to be right it's gotta be
toby right that seemed to be the main
driving force of hype a possibility oh
yeah 100 because i mean you know it's
hubby mcguire's got the three films on
andrew garfield's too and yeah i feel
like tasm too especially has a bad taste
in a lot of people's mouths and so while
the lead-up was happening my impression
that i kept getting was people were like
yeah yeah it'd be cool if andrew
garfield showed up but toby mcguire yeah
so to be coming out of no way home and
to see that the main person we're
hearing about is andrew garfield stole
the show in a lot of people's eyes that
makes me really happy because one thing
what i was telling you like the the day
before we went to the premiere was i
really got the impression upon re-watch
that the amazing spider-man movies just
kind of came out a little bit too soon
you know like if you cut back to when
amazing spider-man came out it was just
a couple years after spider-man 3 there
was the talk of the tomb the spider-man
4 is going to be happening and then they
were even doing an interview saying like
no we want this to be great samurai was
like want to see the best one possible
then they just scrap it and reboot it
it's like this darker version and it's
such an opposite type of spider-man
movie in so many ways i just don't think
people were ready to accept this new
iteration at the time because i remember
liking amazing spider-man 1 a lot but
feeling like uncomfortable to admit that
seemed like everyone right yeah those
movies get a bad rap but especially the
first one i remember enjoying just fine
and then i walked into many spider-man 2
and i went
i actually kind of liked this toy
well i could see the flaws for sure i
kind of like this one
i think it's better than spider-man 3 so
i'm gonna put some dirt in your eye
there's a key moment in no way home that
lends itself to a portion that made me
go
this would be a cool amazing spider-man
3 movie just see when he talks to tom
holland about i gave into my rage i got
consumed by it and i pull him up stop
pulling my punches and when you hear
that you kind of go
man that sounds like a really cool dark
spider-man
in my mind's eye and hearing the
response from people going i wish we
could see that movie and just confirm my
thoughts of see now people will be ready
for a target spider-man movie here right
yeah and i feel like it's also a benefit
that now we've had another recasting of
spider-man in tom holland because part
of the thing that i think dog andrew
garfield aside from the time it took or
didn't take for them to reboot it is the
fact that everyone was married to this
one live-action portrayal barring the
one from the 70s and then you know now
that there have been two i feel like
people will be a lot more open to
whoever steps into the shoes and so now
that's coming back around for andrew
garfield i think the prospect of making
an amazing spider-man 3 that seems like
a big leap it does but after the kind of
year we've had or this one movie i do
start to wonder like
i can see a scenario where it could be
kind of possible that they could do it
especially where you have where the tom
holland one is at that is in the marvel
cinematic universe and as they establish
like not even the avengers exist in the
amazing spider-man world and it's such a
different tone and vibe and placement of
a character and i think what this movie
did really well noah helm was
establishing how just very different the
three of them are that you could do your
own subsection but some of the main
rumors sony's is considering having him
around for multiple projects and this
are making me wonder we did bring this
up on the live stream everything we're
seeing about morbius is just getting
like really freaking confusing because
in no way home norman osborne states
there's no oscorp but in the mortgage
show you see an oscar building so you're
like okay this is must be in the
venomverse but wait a minute and tom
holland's spider-man there's there's no
oscorp and then in the background and
that shot that was going around it's the
tobey maguire spider-man suit in the
playstation game they're like but that
doesn't fit and then at the oscorp
building 2 the logo and oscorp i believe
in the main spider-man is like that
vertical yeah when then the the
marvelous it's this it's the same box
yeah yeah
it's the same fonts or like maybe
maybe
universes maybe it would actually be
andrew garfield's maybe they changed the
photo around it to keep it hidden or
surprised or alright or more bass
basically just confusing and doesn't
know what university exists right like i
i don't i don't know it's weird like i i
was mainly really excited for toby
mcguire to come back then doing the
re-watch just a week before no way home
i was then like really looking forward
to andrew garfield and to see the
response that he's been getting so far
just makes me really [ __ ] happy like
i'm really happy and i hope he's happy
because it really seemed like you know
he just dealt with so much crap and and
then you know like if anyone had like
the most toxic leaving of a relationship
between toby and andrew was andrew it
was such a public discourse thing that
occurred from like the leaks and stuff
and then why they decided to reboot him
like andrew didn't show up for that
meeting and it pissed me off you know
like that whole thing that went down and
then also you know leading into no way
home how he just gets bombarded with it
are you in nowhere are you at home i
don't want it to become like a ben
affleck's batman situation for him where
he gets so turned off again curse now
yeah exactly even that's part of
spider-man but i don't want it to be
like turned off for him at the same time
i love the idea of him continuing to do
this because he really did shine on his
own a lot of no way out yeah and it
seems like his portrayal especially as
even compared to toby maguire seems like
there's a lot more to do there whereas
toby feels more like you know a send-off
a stamp on something that's already got
a legacy whereas yeah andrew seems like
you could do anything with it yes moving
forward but guys
what do you think about the idea of
andrew garfield showing up at some other
maybe in this venomverse side of things
of the spider-man world whatever the
hell this is called leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click that
notification bell hit that like button
and last but not least
rosa parra it's christmas time my dear
so i hope you're having a wonderful time
with your family i hope you're giving
your kids tons of presents tons of love
i hope you have yourself a sexy ass
santa claus to kick with
this
christmas time when the kids go to bed
they got to be asleep for cookies
you got some
but don't make that joke
it's milk related oh yes
you've been such a long time supporter
of our patreon page and we really
appreciate it and i hope 2022 you just
kicked even more ass than you've already
been doing happy new year make it a
blessed one
with some milk
[Music]